this family was luckier than most
after nine days as hostages these men
returned to their loved ones
it was an incredible moment to witness
[Music]
so in a I too kind of fear anger and
hope is present every day in the Central
African Republic since 2013
I've watched as the country battled
against tyrannical as I documented the
civil war for Human Rights Watch in the
beginning it began with the Celica a
rebel coalition that sought to topple
the corrupt government they recruited
foreign fighters and he began to loot
burn and murder their way across the
country to seize power because many of
the Celica were Muslim the religious
minority the rest of the country saw
them as extremists to oppress the
control of car then came the anti-balaka
a grassroots militia that rose up to
fight the Celica rule they began to
attack the Muslim civilians with equal
brutality religion was twisted into a
weapon used to divide the country and
masked what war was really bad
vengeance survival resources and power
and all civilians were caught in the
middle 800,000 people were forced from
their homes neighborhoods burned to the
ground
thousands died the Civil War began this
is what it looks like when a country
shatters but how can it put itself back
together we think of civil war as two
armies facing off but what it really
looks like is everyday moments of terror
in street and as the conflict trickle
down into communities it's spot
tit-for-tat nervous fueled by revenge
[Music]
these people are grieving the death of a
young Christian girl her family members
told us they would seek their own form
of violent justice I'm using my you see
awkward they think that song myself I
[Music]
first saw her present shot and killed by
international peacekeepers then I saw
the machete he used to murder a passing
man on the street even as a funeral it
felt like there was nowhere to hide
galleys anti-balaka Mooji insulin shots
LS silica elegant a long robe this
corner from Flickr is positive as
University Club visited me father
Bernard is a Catholic priest his arms
are around a Muslim child and his church
heart has become a home to Muslim women
children and the elderly
each person he saved me bro point in
McLennan abuse the Commission's on
surgical repair asila casa en fair share
per man to the women in Scientology when
I create a measurement I sukashi
visually problem that I value more a
fair beside predictions I want to face
for Killian you see she's on today's
episode every father Bernard reminded us
that although this is mistakenly made
out to be a religious rule it's not that
simple
it's communities just fighting to
survive
[Music]
while a war raged on cities were under
siege hundreds of people fled to shelter
at an international peacekeepers base
they protected the civilians as celica
and anti-balaka forces traded fire next
morning we were told that more than
1,000 people had been killed across the
country as the conflict bled into the
streets entire villages began hiding
deep in the bush far away from roads or
towns that would make them easy targets
this community had lived in the fields
for seven months when we found
Sujit parent reduce emissions condition
from the shaky-shaky de las Leona's own
separate waffle modem ET comme de la
police vilena me the funkiest own
estimate with that money cut a single
personally we had a tumor in certain my
AC mode if you want blood to cover more
people calipari wasn't about viva la
Macomb sudden city that I love but it
wasn't until September 2014 when the UN
peacekeepers arrived that the violence
would finally died down three years
later the original militias have split
into 14 separate factions controlling
different parts of the country but in
the East a new battleground has emerged
Cara is bursting with gold and diamond
mines
I'll say kill the goose that making all
benefit may challenge farm there's on
farm get chewed up on $60 new me to kill
me licensed architect the rabbinic on
Luverne opposite bask in the very end
was lost women on a triple moisture
shatter the debris go the the summer
Malik Hasani everyone is scrambling for
control of the rich natural resources
and although a new president is elected
in 2016 rebel factions have taken
control of the eastern minds vive le gvz
my Paloma you secure yourself a kiss
install Japan Silesia you secure last
year Washington
close to half a million people still
living crammed refugee camps throughout
car and neighboring countries whether
Christian or Muslim many have no home to
go back to Germany here not a young man
here looking minutes with what lies in
German bash the enemy people tsukushi
legitimately do suck in the Central
African Republic remains a divided
scarred and fragile country and 2017
alone an increase in violence displaced
another 100 thousands of people right
now this story feels like it has no end
just resilient people looking towards an
uncertain future only thing the notion
swap we're like yeah
the morning low like that because you
don't pay
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]